hello and welcome back to the shaky
science show or the spooky science show
I should say to be as since Halloween is
just around the corner I thought I'd do
a Halloween special so I don't think I'd
really describe myself as a scary person
so I really struggled to think of what
to talk about in this video should I
talk about the scariest pre-teens how
many bacteria in your body the effects
of alcohol and liver damage it I don't
really get that one but actually there
was one disease that is truly scary and
it's a disease that currently there's no
cure and that is Alzheimer's disease
so out Simas disease is the most common
neurodegenerative disease and it's
predicted that by 2050 135 million
people will be affected by the disease
and with the cost of $30,000 per person
for treatment in a year that could toll
up to four trillion dollars a huge
amount and a great burden to our society
but once these high costs might cause
some fear for people the truly
devastating outcome of outsiders
received is the effects of memory that
is memory loss and this is because
memory makes our lives enables us to
recognize people make associations hold
conversations reminisce have nostalgia
tell funny jokes and not surprisingly
memory is the key to pick Pixar movies
my favorite animation films of course so
I've actually made two previous videos
that look at both the biochemical
underpinnings of Alzheimer's disease and
also memory formation but in this video
I wanted to really focus on a study that
looks at the role of iris in and out
sciences and predominantly I'll be
focusing on the results from this nature
publication here and this paper came out
earlier this year and makes the
connection between an exercise induced
hormone and memory formation in outside
Miss disease models but firstly a better
background to Alzheimer's disease
so our summer series results the
deterioration of the brain in particular
a region of the brain called the
hippocampus and as already mentioned is
the most common neurodegenerative
disease and it's characterized by the
presence of these protein aggregates
I've amyloid beta plaques which are
found outside the cell or neuro for
glaring towel tangles that are found
inside the cell and say the condition
can either be caused through a familial
and inherited defective genes or they
could happen sporadically and so it's
been reported that there is a link
between increased amounts of physical
exercise and potentially a decreased
rate or incidence rates of getting
Alzheimer's disease so this paper tries
to further explore this link and does it
by looking at the link between Ireson
and outside mr. C's so well what is iris
in so with its name derived from the
goddess iris messenger of the gods and
also the goddess or frame days hence I
can finally use my Ruby pen iris in is a
Maya kind it's a hormone secreted by
muscles and so the signal comes from the
muscle and can then travel and is
thoughts in the current model to the
brain where it can further signal that
exercise is being undertaken so the name
comes more from the messenger side than
anything to do a frame days
unfortunately and iris sin isn't just
made as Ireson it is the right and
cleaves from precursor that is referred
to as fibronectin type 3 domain
containing protein 5 or fndc 5 so the
idea is that iris and then travels up to
the brain and stimulates expression of
brain derived neurotrophic factor BDNF
which is involved in learning and memory
and so that's kind of the link between
the Tuesday far but one of the problems
with iris in being dried from a
precursor means that detecting Ireson as
opposed to detecting fndc v can be quite
tricky and that's important when we want
to understand the signaling mechanism
involved with iris in signaling
nonetheless the team addressed that this
was an issue and they tried to be aware
of this for out the study so what they
first did was try to see how do these
levels of Ariston ferry in patients with
them about outside Miss disease and what
they could see is patients with
Alzheimer's disease and also a model
mouse models that's meant to mimic
out-science disease they see lower
levels of Ireson in particular the
levels myosin were lower in the cerebral
spinal fluids of outside mr. C's
patients and fear both genetic and
pharmacological approaches they reduce
the levels of Ireson in the brains of
normal mice and this appeared to impair
their certain types of memory and then
there are first effects of increasing
the levels of arizim boosted their
memory and rescued these impairments
which kind of proves the link between
Ireson and memory defect and then one of
the really neat things that they did as
can be seen in this graph here is that
they gave recombinant Ireson and
conditions with and without these alpha
beta holidays and what they found was
the recombinant iris and actually
rescued the impaired neuro transmissions
caused by the alpha beta holidays and so
that kind of also shows a link between
outside sources and iris levels now what
could somewhat be arcades that these are
more correlations they necessarily cause
Asians one of the interesting parts from
this study is the question of could iris
in be used as a biomarker and also could
exercise being more encouraged as a
potential therapeutic to tackle the
onset of Alzheimer's disease the issue
of that is obviously dementia is an age
associated condition and there's also
other comorbidities as well such as
arthritis heart disease obesity and so
else ice isn't necessarily the most
ideal solution but could we mimic the
effects of Ireson and so to be able to
mimic the effects of Ireson we kind of
really need to understand what is iris
and interacting with what is the
receptor that it's binding to you in the
neurons if there is a receptor and so
these additional questions need to be
answered before we take this any further
but it's pretty cool pretty neat and
shows that a lot of work is being put
into outside Mercy's so hopefully at
some points and some point soon we can
have a better cure of outside mrs. ease
so hopefully this helps you have a good
introduction to web apps and thank you
for listening